[Musique]
on est aujourd'hui à Boston alors je
vous emmène à Boston pourquoi pour venir
vous parler d'une boîte que vous
connaissez une très grosse boîte
d'ailleurs vous l'avez probablement déjà
vu dans le titre on va se parler
d'Amazon c'est la première fois
qu'Amazon fait venir des journalistes du
monde entier donc il y a du monde il y a
des médias qui viennent du monde entier
pour venir découvrir leurs entrepôts et
pour parler de robotique alors on se
parle ici de robotique de robotique pour
les entrepôts d'Amazon l'idée c'est
s'appelle délivring de future l'idée
c'est de venir voir ce qui va se passer
qu'elle va être le futur d'Amazon au
niveau des entrepôts comment est-ce
qu'ils vont introduire plus de robotique
pour venir soulager les gens qui
travaillent pour venir améliorer la
cadence peut-être même pour remplacer de
l'humain j'en sais foutrement rien donc
là on est le matin il est 7h32 dans une
demi-heure on prend des bus pour partir
directement chez Amazon pour voir la
conférence et des conférences il y aura
des démonstrations donc je vous emmène
avec moi en immersion on va venir
découvrir le futur d'Amazon ici à Boston
et puis attendons on va profiter de la
vue parce que c'est juste magnifique
[Musique]
on vient d'arriver chez Amazon alors
vous avez derrière toute une partie
robotique de robots qui bosse tout seul
on va regarder il y a une con il y a pas
mal de choses donc l'idée c'est de venir
voir en fait ce qui se passe ici c'est
que on est au Bose 27 c'est le nom du
lieu on est pas très loin de Boston et
on va retrouver ici tout des innovations
il y a beaucoup de R&D qui est faite ici
pour optimiser la création même pour
venir créer tout simplement des robots
l'idée c'est de se dire ok comment
est-ce qu'on peut optimiser dans les
entrepôts comment est-ce qu'on peut
créer des outils qui vont éviter que les
gens viennent se fatiguer en manipulant
des choses lourdes en ayant des charges
avantages seront compliquées comment
est-ce qu'on arrive optimiser tout ça
comment est-ce qu'on arrive à emmener de
la robotique pour que ça ait un sens ici
chez Amazon donc il y a toute une partie
de R&D qui se fait ici on va travailler
sur l'intelligence artificielle sur de
la robotique sur du machine learning sur
différentes Zia pour arriver à des
solutions qui serviront aussi bien dans
les entrepôts pour tout ce qui va être
et bien enlever les palettes à venir
préparer des commandes que pour ensuite
des véhicules Auton pour la livraison en
tout cas c'est le principe aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'on va venir regarder donc je
vous emmène et vous allez voir emmener
ça va être extrêmement intéressant tout
se passe ici là il y a un compte qui
avoir lieu ici d'ici quelques instants
et on est directement dans les entrepôts
d'Amazon là où ils sont en train de
travailler sur tout ce qui va être R&D
vous êtes toute la robotique qui est
derrière là c'est vraiment un entrepôt
qui est reconstitué pour venir bosser
ici sur toute la partie une fois de plus
développement R&D des robots et là c'est
surtout pour la partie entrepôt partie
manufacture
[Applaudissements]
alors on est chez Amazon Robotics je
vous explique on a fait un tour complet
on a regardé je vais pouvoir tout vous
expliquer ici Amazon fabrique qu'on soit
fabrique eux-mêmes directement leur
propre robots super intéressant les
chaînes de fabrication sont juste
derrière entre autres il y a pas que que
là mais il fabrique des robots il les
conçoivent tout ce qui ne fabrique pas
ici tous les éléments toutes les pièces
tout ce qui ne peuvent pas concevoir ils
le font venir de l'étranger mais l'idée
en fait ici c'est très très malin c'est
qu'Amazon se dit ok nous on connaît nos
besoins on maîtrise nos entrepôts on
sait ce qu'on veut comme robot donc du
coup on va venir les fabriquer vous
allez voir qu'il y a différents types de
robots qui vont répondre à différents
usages et alors je vous en montre un
chacun le meilleur pour la fin ce robot
là il vient d'être montré pour la
première fois au monde à des gens de
l'extérieur d'Amazon et ça vous allez
voir ça c'est intéressant parce que ça
montre une fois de plus la capacité
d'innovation de cette marque qui est
juste absolument incroyable
ce que je vous montre c'est la
fabrication de robots ils sont conçus
l'idée c'est d'arriver à ce robot là et
on vient ici le concevoir les fabriquer
donc vous avez une chaîne alors je sais
plus combien ils nous ont dit mais le
nom de robots qui peuvent fabriquer par
jour et jusqu'au lossal l'idée c'est de
fabriquer pour le déployer donc tous les
entrepôts Amazon du monde donc ici c'est
la conception c'est la fabrication et
vous avez les chaînes qui sont situées
juste ici à Boston regardez hop là lui
il est en train d'arriver il va être
posé après donc il est emmené par un
espèce de très grand bras articulé et il
descend tranquille où au sol voilà
peinard jusqu'à ensuite pouvoir être je
suppose tester et être fonctionnel en
tout cas voilà comment ça fonctionne lui
on le revers un peu plus tard vous allez
voir c'est aussi très intéressant
entre parties on vient tester les robots
juste ici alors ils ont fait un truc
très marrant chez Amazon c'est que pour
les tester il leur donne des petits noms
donc là vous avez des espèces de je sais
pas comment ils appellent ça des espèces
d'ensemble dans lesquelles le robots
vont être pour venir les tester
indépendamment donc ils sont très très
Marvel donc là je sais pas si vous voyez
bien mais là on a Wolverine et on a à
côté Hulk on retrouve cyborg on retrouve
bref ils nous font un peu tous les
Marvel qu'on pourrait retrouver ici
l'idée une fois toutes je pense que
c'est des gros geeks sont des gros
enfants ici ils se font plaisir donc ici
on va retrouver toute la calibration au
niveau des robots alors là vous les
retrouvez pour l'instant ils sont pas
très très fonctionnels il y en a
quelques-uns qui vont se déplacer par là
ils font un circuit et en fait le truc à
savoir ici c'est que il se déplace pas
tout seul vous avez au sol des petits
comme des espèces de
QR code en fait qui leur servent de
repère pour venir se déplacer ils vont
venir les lire ils vont venir les suivre
alors eux ils sont pas du tout adaptés
pour pouvoir vivre avec de l'humain à
côté parce que ils vont pas les
reconnaître contrairement à un robot que
je vais vous montrer juste après par
contre ils font regardez celui-là hop là
il se déplace il sort de son petit box
là-bas il va se balader il va suivre son
petit bonhomme de chemin et à la fin
regardez ils viennent ils passent par
là-bas ils vont derrière voilà comment
ça se passe pour la calibration des
robots qui se passe ici donc une fois
qu'ils ont été construits qu'ils ont été
testés fonctionnels et ils sont je pense
ensuite expédié pour partir dans
différents entrepôts d'Amazon donc là
vous voyez le robot avec une charge donc
il va pouvoir venir déplacer les
étagères alors le principe en fait c'est
que ce petit robot là lorsqu'il va être
dans l'entrepôt Amazon il va venir
déplacer directement les étagères pour
les emmener directement un point de
picking pour être mis dans les colis ça
évite qu'il y a des humains qui les
déplacent qui ça se mal au dos bref
c'est une fois de plus une solution pour
que ça aille plus vite et même vous
voyez parce que ils vont venir
entreposer ils vont venir coller
directement les étagères comme ça et une
fois de plus un vrai gain d'espace pour
Amazon dans les entrepôts comme ça ils
ont pas besoin de pousser les murs c'est
pas comme si vous avez quelqu'un qui
venait et qui devait circuler ici les
étagères se déplacent à la différence
des humains qui viennent déplacer les
étagères
faire redondance aurait tendance pour
les petites pincettes quand je dis ça à
devenir une référence en termes de
robots autonome qui vont pouvoir
rencontrer des humains voilà ça c'est
l'idée en tout cas ce que ça montre
c'est que l'homme et la machine peuvent
travailler conjointement la machine ici
on pourrait se dire à vocation à
remplacer l'homme je suis pas convaincu
moi je pense vraiment je suis très très
sincère je pense vraiment que ici on
vient se délester de tâches qui sont
hyper compliquées qui sont hyper lourdes
qui sont fastidieuses qui font mal on
vient porter des charges ici c'est pas
le cas ici c'est la machine qui va gérer
ça l'humain est là pour piloter l'humain
est là pour apporter l'intelligence pour
apporter la science et la machine est là
pour faire les tâches qui sont
réellement sans vrai valeur ajoutée
prendre un colis faire du picking le
poser l'emmener faire un colis
aujourd'hui c'est pas une vraie grosse
valeur ajoutée donc je trouve ça bien
que dans l'idée attention Amazon je dis
pas que c'est la boîte parfaite et
compagnie hein probablement beaucoup de
choses à venir reprocher au gars femme
ici mais en tout cas ce qui est bien
c'est que ils vont prendre leurs
employés ils vont les faire monter en
compétences ils vont leur permettre de
travailler dans des domaines de haute
technologie la robotique ici notamment
et ça leur permet effectivement
d'améliorer la productivité ça permet
d'améliorer les capacités de stockage
les capacités de livraison même
d'ailleurs il y a plein de points qui
sont super intéressants et même la
question de la livraison au dernier
kilomètre que là on n'a pas vu mais
j'avais déjà vu un petit robot lorsque
j'étais à rimars au mois de juin à Las
Vegas un petit robot qui peut-être aller
savoir pourrait venir vous livrer chez
vous et puis on part également aussi de
livraison via le drone donc c'est aussi
un sujet qui est intéressant c'est le
dernier kilomètre parce que vous le
savez Amazon aujourd'hui ils sont quoi
ils ont des gros camions ils viennent
livrer directement chez les gens mais la
notion du dernier kilomètre R2
l'entrepôt jusqu'à chez vous et bien sur
un sujet important alors aujourd'hui ça
se fait avec différents transporteurs
mais peut-être que demain Amazon
arrivera à tout gérer par lui-même de
façon autonome on en est très clairement
pas là mais est-ce que vous pourriez
voir dites-le-moi en commentaire
d'ailleurs un robot arrivé chez vous ou
un drone posé le paquet dans votre
jardin est-ce que pour vous c'est un
sens ou pas du tout dites-le-moi juste
en bas
[Applaudissements]
autre mot qui est intéressant c'est
celui là qu'on a juste en face regardez
c'est Robin alors Robini fait quoi ce
qui va arriver ici c'est différents
types de colis on va avoir des
enveloppes on va avoir des paquets voir
différentes choses lui il va venir les
reconnaître il va les prendre
directement avec son bras et il va venir
les poser ensuite sur les robots qui
vont les transporter et les emmener
directement pour que ça parte ensuite
dans le camion et que ça arrive jusqu'à
chez vous l'idée et l'intelligence ici
c'est de reconnaître les différents
types de formats on va pas porter une
enveloppe de la même manière qu'on va
venir apporter un carton on va pas le
faire tout à fait pareil l'idée c'est de
reconnaître le paquet d'adapter
effectivement et bien la machine pour
venir le déposer et éviter que ça
s'abîme donc une fois de plus on est sur
de la robotique on est sur l'espèce de
grand bras mécanique avec une tonne de
capteurs de tous les côtés et puis
regarder une fois de plus je vous le
disais tout à l'heure vous avez tous ces
robots là qui viennent se déplacer alors
là c'est un espèce de balai de rebond on
dirait que c'est en train de danser mais
si vous regardez bien une fois tous au
sol vous avez tous ces capteurs et vous
avez les traces des robots qui viennent
se déplacer autour donc là on va pas
mettre un pied ici sans quoi on
risquerait d'avoir globalement des
problèmes mais ça permet une fois de
plus de voir comment ça fonctionne et de
se projeter dans les entreprises
d'Amazon
c'est une nouveauté en fait le truc qui
est vraiment vraiment intéressant avec
ce robot là c'est la première fois
qu'Amazon va venir montrer ce robot
alors je vous explique ce qu'il fait ici
c'est Sparro c'est pas haut il va venir
récupérer dans des petites caisses que
vous avez normalement juste là sur la
droite il vient récupérer des éléments
et il va venir par un système
d'aspiration c'est un truc assez
intéressant avec ce robot c'est que en
fait ce que vous avez là ça vient
aspirer donc là vous en avez plusieurs
et en fait en fonction du colis il va
venir le reconnaître parmi toutes les
références que vous avez chez Amazon il
va venir aspirer et il va venir déposer
délicatement dans la caisse les produits
qui ensuite partiront directement pour
être livré c'est vraiment une innovation
qui est assez marrant parce qu'en fait
vous avez vraiment robot un bras
articulé avec des caméras avec des
tonnes de capteurs qui va être en
capacité de reconnaître le produit c'est
ça déjà le faire mais surtout sans venir
abîmer aucun produit parce que imaginez
là où vous allez avoir par exemple une
enveloppe là où vous allez avoir une
bouteille là vous allez avoir un livre
un livre typiquement il va venir le
prendre délicatement alors il va savoir
où le prendre parce que si vous le prend
là où la page se lève il va venir le
défoncer donc pas du tout en fait ce qui
va venir faire lui c'est prendre il sait
où le prendre il le dépose et ça c'est
assez malin parce qu'en fait c'est le
produit qui manquait aujourd'hui enfin
en tout cas il y en a peut-être d'autres
en tout cas c'est un produit qui
manquait chez Amazon pour venir prendre
les produits directement c'est ce qu'on
appelle le picking et c'est ce que font
les gens qui travaillent chez Amazon le
picking ne se fait pas directement par
l'humain se fait par le robot ça vient
une fois de plus améliorer tout le
process ça vient éviter les erreurs déjà
que j'ai déjà vu quand j'avais fait
l'émission Ça va cartonner que tout le
process de dire était vraiment vraiment
limité il venait scanner vérifier contre
vérifier contre valider donc jusque là
il y avait pas de souci donc ce système
là est assez malin le système là et
intelligent et ça montre une fois de
plus que on va venir remplacer des
tâches fastidieuses de l'homme par des
machines alors après attends c'est on va
se dire ici on supprime des emplois je
vous entends je sais je vous entends et
vous avez raison alors le fait c'est que
non parce que Amazon crée énormément
d'emploi je sais plus combien
aujourd'hui c'est des milliers d'emplois
qu'ils ont créé pour venir s'occuper de
leur robotique et ils forment des gens
ils les envoient justement et une
personne qui me disait qu'il arrive
assez je sais plus combien de semaines
peut-être 12 semaines à venir se former
pour travailler sur les robots pour les
entretenir pour s'en occuper bref il y a
de vrais emplois qui se créent
énormément ce ne sont pas des
destructions d'emploi ce sont des
constructions d'emploi alors pour autant
je saurai pas vous calculer le ratio
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ici Amazon
va gagner en productivité va gagner en
autonomie va gagner en capacité de
stockage et c'est assez mal
[Applaudissements]
là j'ai un Amazon
c'est juste là où il y a le camion de
livraison électrique Amazon on parle
aussi de drones je sais pas si on va le
voir ici ok alors
il y a beaucoup de monde si vous suivez
vous savez que Amazon je vous ai parlé
de la robotique la robotique c'est tout
ce qu'on a dans les entrepôts maintenant
il y a la question du dernier kilomètre
de la livraison la livraison ici elle se
fait via un camion électrique camion
Amazon via un drone alors aux États-Unis
pas en France mais ça pourrait arriver
des drones également il y a plein de
façons de venir livrer c'est ce qu'on va
regarder tout de suite
donc ça c'est le nouveau drone on va
pouvoir retrouver pour aller se faire
livrer alors on parle bien aussi dans le
drone aux États-Unis pas en France mais
il est très grand très impressionnant et
je sais pas s'il a législation sera
prête c'est toujours la question de
façon de la législation qui compte ici
dès que la législation sera prête et lui
permettra probablement pourra-t-on se
faire livrer en France en tout cas c'est
déjà le cas aux US avec un drone
petit aparté expérience de réalité
virtuelle ou Amazon pour parler
justement de son drone qui est juste là
va mettre des journalistes dans des
cartons faux cartons Amazon avec de la
réalité augmentée comme ça en voyage on
peut voir ce que ça va être la livraison
drone mais je trouve que la symbolique
est assez rigolote c'est bête mais ça me
fait rire donc là c'est marrant parce
qu'il vous montre tous les objets qui
peuvent être potentiellement livrés via
un drone donc un fire stick forcément 4K
il montre leurs produits Amazon ça je
sais pas ce que c'est de la nourriture
des objets en fait je pense de de petits
pois c'est vraiment le truc qui est
important je parle vraiment de points je
parle pas de petits pois quand je dis ça
des cartouches d'encre voilà il y a
plein de trucs donc un petit formats qui
vont potentiellement pouvoir être livré
directement par un drone et voilà c'est
assez marrant alors pour ça arrive il
faut que la législation soit prête il
faut que la réglementation en Europe
c'est loin d'être fait en Europe en
France soit près pour avoir de la
livraison par drone mais ça pourrait
potentiellement arriver parce que de
toute façon ça commence souvent par des
pays comme les États-Unis qui vont
montrer un peu la voix et ensuite ça
pour arriver en France je sais pas ce
que vous en pensez moi je trouve ça
marrant cette livraison par drone et
l'idée il disait c'est de se faire
livrer en une heure donc vous passez
votre commande et en une heure vous êtes
livré et même a priori à un moment on
parlait d'une demi-heure donc imaginez
vous êtes sur Amazon vous êtes prime
vous faites forcément client prime et
vous faites livrer en une demi-heure
alors pas partout j'imagine pas que dans
des grandes villes comme Paris vous ayez
le drone qui arrive au-dessus de la
ville quoique parce qu'il y a toujours
la question de l'espace aérien mais
peut-être peut-être que ça arrivera
c'est assez marrant imaginez qui est
vachement cool c'est une fois de plus
pour tout ce qui va être en droit un peu
désertique dans des campagnes où c'est
compliqué vous êtes en haut de montagne
et bien vous vous faites livrer ça
existe déjà je sais que la poste le fait
ça de la livraison dans la vallée il y a
le postier qui arrive il fait partie son
drone ensuite il le récupère et il le
pose dans le village enfin un truc qui
est assez malin Amazon de faire ça
Amazon pourrait arriver là-dessus aussi
en France avoir si vraiment ça sera le
cas et si oui à quelle horizon
un autre sujet qui est important c'est
la livraison par camion camion Amazon
alors Amazon un partenariat racheté des
actions dans la boîte s'appelle Riviane
je connaissais pas pour tout vous dire
et donc du coup ils ont leur propre
camion les camions Amazon qu'ils ont
complètement customisé l'idée c'est de
se dire ok ils veulent mettre en avant
la sécurité la sécurité de leurs
employés la sécurité aussi des autres
personnes qui vont être sur la route
pour être sûr que vous soyez livré dans
de bonnes conditions qui est pas de
questions qui viennent se poser sur la
sécurité sont vraiment très à cheval
là-dessus ils ont extrêmement raison
donc ça c'est le premier point surtout
de l'électrique pourquoi et bien pour le
côté 0 carbone 0 émission de carbone ça
c'est quand même vachement bien et puis
une fois de plus tout est optimisé par
exemple ici il y a pas de clé lorsque le
chauffeur est dans les 5 mètres et bien
le véhicule reste ouvert mais dès qu'il
a passé les 5 mètres le véhicule se
verrouille automatiquement les portes se
ferme donc bon ils viennent vraiment
optimiser une fois de plus pour que la
livraison se fasse dans les meilleurs
délais dans les meilleures conditions de
façon un peu invisible pour l'humain qui
va venir conduire son camion il prend
son colis il pose il repart c'est simple
mais par contre tout est maîtrisé d'un
point de vue technologique
faire une visite du camion regardez on
monte par là là c'est dégagé de tous les
côtés alors c'est vraiment épuré de chez
épuré on va voir juste avoir des
informations ici pour le conducteur pour
qu'il voit effectivement où aller une
petite table de bord effectivement
pareil alors j'imagine qu'ici va avoir
des informations sur les clients savoir
où aller tous l'itinéraire avec le GPS
pour qu'ils viennent pas se poser trop
de questions et puis ensuite à
l'intérieur on va retrouver tous les
endroits où se reposer tous les colis à
droite à gauche c'est totalement
optimisé alors j'imagine qu'on met des
petites étiquettes mais voyez on peut
même en avoir à l'arrière là qui sont
relevés et qui vont pouvoir être posées
un petit chariot pour venir prendre les
colis qui est juste là et puis surtout
cette espèce de grande porte là
coulissante qui vient qui se referme
comme ça c'est plutôt bien vu parce
qu'une fois de plus le sujet qui est
extrêmement important et intéressant
aussi c'est la question des derniers
kilomètres alors on voit ici globalement
qu'est-ce qui se passe Amazon fabrique
des robots pour gérer les entrepôts pour
gérer le picking pour gérer le
déplacement des produits dans les
entrepôts pour les emmener pour ensuite
prendre les cartons les trier les mettre
directement dans les colis puis ensuite
ils arrivent dans des camions donc il
voyage d'entrepôts d'entrepôt et crois
qu'ils arrivent dans le bon entrepôt et
bien la question des années de
kilomètres est gérée soit par le
véhicule Amazon totalement électrique
soit livraison par un drone qui est
derrière là-bas en tout cas ça c'est le
schéma complet Amazon tel qu'on peut
l'imaginer comme ça aujourd'hui c'est
pas dit que ça arrivera complètement en
France mais on voit qu'il y a une vraie
évolution qui se fait chez Amazon cette
volonté de tous simplifier de tout
rendre plus sécurisé que ce soit pour
protéger toutes les personnes qui
travaillent chez Amazon ou bien pour
optimiser totalement cette chaîne de
livraison je trouve ça plutôt marrant
intéressant ça montre là où ils vont
comment une boîte hyper technologique
comme Amazon cherchait à aller au
travers de ces différentes innovations
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez dites
le moi dans les commentaires alors je
sais pas si ça vous intéresse qu'on
parle comme ça vous voyez de regarder un
peu les coulisses d'une boîte savoir
comment fonctionne un géant comme Amazon
dites-le-moi en bas on s'en reparlera on
s'en fera peut-être d'autres comme ça si
ça vous botte en tout cas voilà moi
c'est une expérience que je trouve très
intéressante le fait que amazon ouvre
pour la première fois aux médias les
portes ici d'un centre de recherche de
fabrication où ils viennent vraiment
montrer les coulisses c'est la première
fois première fois au monde vous voyez
ils ouvrent un petit peu les vannes il
permet de montrer comme ça ça évangélise
un petit peu les populations je pense
poussent un peu leur idée derrière mais
voilà moi je trouve ça plutôt cool
intéressant alors après attention on
parle ici d'Amazon il y a toujours des
choses qu'on pourrait venir reprocher au
niveau de la consommation au niveau des
petites boutiques cette plus compliqué
pour eux mais pour autant voilà c'est le
fonctionnement il est là il est
intéressant et on en parle dites-moi ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
comment vous trouvez vous tous ces
systèmes de robot tout ce que met en
place Amazon tout le système Amazon ça
va de la robotique au travers des
derniers kilomètres avec des véhicules
électriques au travers de la livraison
par drone marquez moi ça en bas dans les
commentaires nous on se retrouve très
vite pour continuer à parler tech ça
c'est chouette je vous embrasse bisous à
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]